welcome to this video playing oopsis
axis axis axis 27 from Spain okay maybe
the Kings Indian my audioletter 3
usually indicating g3 know okay so we
got the classical again aha the maca
gone off with the h3 which i also have
played a number of times and it seems is
ignite h5 ian i th five has gained some
popularity recently because they are
funny funny lines with the quick be
sacrifice I looked at this and came to
the conclusion that I shouldn't allow it
is white but I totally forgot how
exactly it is played okay but Bishop g5
is a slightly strange move I am a same
it does not pin anything and I already
had the night on h 5v 98 as an answer
and now it's it's it's a liability this
piece note that takes the ef5 GF 595
there's Queenie five yeah even bishop
behalf he cannot take on on on age five
and he's taking some time on night b5 I
can just cover with an IDs in night a
six
hmm okay so but I always wanted to take
with the pawn and no reason not to yeah
all night a six would be the normal
response I guess that's okay yeah i know
is playing quickly i wonder i really
wonder how to how to play this you form
this may be 94 coming it's probably not
bad but also not helping much Knight f6
night cream yeah okay let's let's play a
developing news I really want to know
what wine is going to do in terms of
castling there is sometimes they just
play long castles and then it's
obviously really am a different
different story okay original ideals
take your plane I'd c5 but
maybe I can just take em play cringes
six come on why not I mean I don't have
it I'm not bad here in an endgame a few
trades i have a center after the central
line no that's nice I have a good center
and no particular problem night can go
to f4 to f6 sometimes I can maybe take
on b5 play night c5 entering the game
must be a better time though capture on
b5 that to make sure that the sea point
is not getting terribly weak yeah but I
have night f4i half Bishop Knight f6 not
sure what's better either force not a
bad news Bishop e3 is not playable 93
check night XP two wins wins material he
cannot castle now
can I can even think of taking on b5 and
play play night before yeah to be honest
I think this is quite good night c 2
threatens the win over rook and also
there is night c22 if to d4 occupying a
fantastic post on the forum
yeah he has a very much and he's got
serious difficulties in covering all
that and d5 is also hanging twice um
yeah however if i take d5 Bishop c4 is a
very is a somewhat awkward pin but i
have c six actually okay maybe here and
just see six there's no no real problem
with that i think yeah i can i can
really just go back here all the way
Bishop c4 c6 all night back and then c6
this is not ideal but ok it's a central
pawn and I'm willing to do some
contortions to witness the to win a good
central pawn
ok so now move the king and get out of
the pin but where maybe just here and
then to e7 there's no reason not to
centralize the king and then Knight b6
next might be six yep yeah maybe just
and then maybe night f7 ok ok I'm about
a minute ahead on the clock and there is
no counter play inside regrouping the
night to see five
jan night on the way to c5 that's not
not bad square and now I need to get the
rooks into play c6 you cannot hear my
nazi six open up the Queen side okay now
the beef I'll can be used for the rooks
now that's that that's nice okay maybe
night to d4 Knight to deform roop c6
even covered with check yeah that so
that's a disaster time when a checkmate
I'd like to meet him here no maid I
don't don't see am hm there should be
one but I don't find it check-in
tendency for check
I can actually just take it before as
made checkmate yep always nice to meet
with the pawn so yeah this was a bit of
an opening disaster around here yeah
after Queen g6 he must retreat the Queen
I think trading Queens I don't know I
don't know I the computer is in fact
actually agreeing with this maybe there
is a technical problem that I'm not
aware if white retreats yeah night FY
it's not bad not bad of course e to g 2
yeah yeah black is probably okay anyway
but this is absolutely not holding any
terrorists and here I'm just winning
winning material and probably with it
the game in the long run check yeah it's
just very very strong for black and I
guess white has no particular defense
here really and I'm not sure then this
capture and everything it does not feel
totally right but that here Bishop h6
seems to lead to some trouble okay
thanks for watching